Now, before we dive into actually creating our sequence,
there are a few core principles or structures
that we need to understand as it
relates to translating traditional film
terminology to game development or at least a game engine.
So some of the engine terminology
that we've used, which you probably know about,
are things like static and skeletal meshes.
We have actors, pawns, characters.
We have worlds, maps, levels.
Level sequences, control rig, which is a animation feature
that we have available in the engine, volumes.
In fact, we will talk about using trigger volumes when
we do our shot creation process,
blueprints, as well as source control.
Some of our sequence or terminology
that's important to understand is scene assemblies.
So this is going to be as we bring things together
collectively.
We have performance takes.
We have sets, layouts, and staging,
which will be very similar to our world maps and levels,
but we're going to be using that terminology slightly
different as we're doing our assembly process.
Level sequences and shot sequences, as well as just
shots.
In this particular slide, on the left,
we have more traditional film terminology.
And with that, we have things like a film,
like a feature or short film.
We have acts, so various different major blocks
within our film storytelling process.
We have sequences, scenes, shots, and takes.
And on the right, we have the terminology
that we traditionally use when it
comes to establishing these same things with Unreal.
So we have things like film or a master sequence.
For our act that we would call in film,
we call that more or less just a level sequence.
And then you'll see we have a level sequence
within the actual sequence, the scene itself.
Again, keep in mind that a sequence is really
just a container.
It's how we use it that changes the way that it operates
and it functions within the engine.
And then, of course, after our level sequence,
we have shots and we have takes.
Now, something to keep in mind here
is that even though this terminology is something
that's often widely adopted by the industry,
it doesn't necessarily mean that you have to use this
verbatim.
The most important thing when it comes to establishing
Sequencer or your Sequencer workflow
is make sure that you have a system that's both scalable
and simple enough that the average person can understand
its core structure, how to use it, et cetera.
The last thing you want to do is get towards the end
of production and realize you have content spread
everywhere within your project.
So again, on this slide, this is really more
just guideposts to help you when it comes
to establishing your workflow with Sequencer
and how to best organize it based off
of the traditional principles of film.
Now, there are a few plugins that are often used
in game development.
Now, one major caveat is all of the plugins
that we have here on the screen,
you don't necessarily have to have these plugins enabled
if you're going to be working within game development.
As an example, you may not have any motion capture suits
or using the AR kit from Apple to do, like,
for example, facial capture.
So you could disable the Apple AR kit and Live Link.
However, if you are using that workflow,
you're going to want to have those plugins enabled.
And you can see that there are a series
of other different plugins that translate
to allowing you to create those real-time sequences
or to be able to do motion capture, right?
Things that are often used in game development
as it relates to creating cinematics, in-game cut scenes,
or anything where Sequencer would come into play.